los vídeos comenzaron a compartirse sin
freno anoche en las redes sociales
chinas y muchos hablaban de un momento
de indignación colectiva solo comparable
al que sucedió tras la muerte del doctor
lihuenland al principio de la pandemia
esta vez son protestas masivas en ruso y
la capital provincial en la que se ve a
los ciudadanos frente al consistorio
enfrentándose a los funcionarios y
pidiendo a gritos el final de Los
confinamientos por un cheese el último
escenario de las protestas contra la
política cero covid buena parte de sus
cuatro millones de habitantes han
sufrido durante casi tres meses
importantes restricciones de movimiento
Así que la paciencia estaba al límite ya
cuando el jueves se produjo un incendio
en el que murieron 10 personas y nueve
quedaron heridas los ciudadanos culpan a
las restricciones del acerokovic de esas
muertes dicen que
retrasaron la salida de los vecinos del
mueble o que impidieron que
Camión de bomberos se acercara más al
edificio las autoridades han desmentido
esas versiones pero esta mañana de forma
sorprendente han anunciado que se van a
relajar de inmediato las medidas de
confinamiento China sufre el peor brote
desde el inicio de la pandemia esta
semana alcanzaba los 35.000 casos
diarios más que en abril cuando tuvo que
ser cerrabas a High durante casi tres
meses Pero esta vez encontraste con lo
que ocurría entonces los casos están muy
repartidos en ciudades tan importantes
como Pekín chonjing o Quan you